l'équipe senior de trappes termine sa
saison de promotion d'honneur par un
match nul les oranje quatrième avant la
rencontre ont été tenus en échec par le
cinquième racing colombes à domicile ce
dimanche
mené au score 1 0 dès le début de la
seconde période des trappistes qui
jouait sans remplaçants ont réagi en
marquant un coup franc à l'entrée de la
surface de réparation par malik el de go
je m'entraîne beaucoup à l'entraînement
et les joueurs me font confiance on le
fait tous confiance et on a j'ai tenté
ma chance et j'ai j'ai marqué quoi
malgré une dernière occasion la 85e
minute rap n'arrive pas à arracher la
victoire dans ce match sans enjeu
un résultat vécu comme une
contre-performance par les joueurs on a
voulu finir en beauté mais
malheureusement on prend le match nul
c'est pas moi c'est pour moi où on joue
les matches à fond quel que soit l'enjeu
on n'y a pas de matches amicaux comme on
dit et donc ni match sans enjeu on joue
pour gagner chaque fois ci nous 1940 au
classement l'étoile sportive de trappes
termina saison la quatrième place avec
un bilan de 10 victoires 6 nuls et 6
défaites
en fait on encore le public très jeune
donc avec défauts et qualités de la
jeunesse à un manque de maturité donc il
faut continuer a pas très longtemps cela
ne soit plus considéré beaucoup de bons
jeunes qui a accaparé suite là
aujourd'hui pour information dans les
équipes de jeunes qui sont montés en
desserrant 17 et donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le club et pour l'avenir
avant de se projeter sur la saison
prochaine dernier match de la saison
dimanche prochain à domicile contre
l'équipe une du racing colombes en coupe
de france